ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen es
ist eine Herrschaft der Angst die
Wladimir Putin in Russland errichtet die
letzten Tage zeigen dass umso deutlicher
verschiedene Urteile und Entscheidungen
machen klar wie gnadenlos das Regime
gegen seine Gegner vorgeht einer der
sich nicht zum Schweigen bringen lässt
der dafür auch mit dem
Friedensnobelpreis ausgezeichnet wurde
ist heute bei uns in der Sendung Jan
raczynski der Vorsitzende der
Menschenrechtsorganisation Memorial
zugeschaltet aus Moskau guten Abend Herr
raschinski
es ist eine er ist einer der letzten
Kremlkritiker die weiterhin ihre Eltern
haben ich möchte aber was präzisieren
ich möchte sagen der Friedensnobelpreis
wurde nicht mehr zugeteilt sondern der
Menschenrechtsorganisation Memorial das
ist ein wichtiger Unterschied das wollte
ich klarstellen und sie waren derjenige
der ihn damals entgegengenommen hat
stellvertretend für diese Organisation
und sie sind einer der letzten
grammelkritiker die so offen ihre
Meinung äußern und dass das zunehmend
gefährlich ist das zeigen gerade die
letzten Tage und wir schauen uns mal
genauer an warum
dieses Bild sorgte für aussehen und
Gerichtsverfahren gemalt hat es die
13-Jährige Mascha im Kunstunterricht die
Schulleitung ruft die Polizei der
russische Geheimdienst behauptet später
Maschas Vater habe sich auf Social Media
kritisch über russische Streitkräfte
geäußert Ende März wird er zu zwei
Jahren Gefängnis verurteilt ob er auch
das Sorgerecht verliert sollte heute
verhandelt werden der Termin ist
verschoben
was es heißt sich kritisch über Putin
und Russlands Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine zu äußern weiß auch er Kreml
Kritiker Ilja Yashin am Mittwoch wird
seine Berufung von einem russischen
Gericht abgelehnt das Urteil bleibt
achteinhalb Jahre Haft im straflage für
das Verbreiten von sogenannten
Falschinformationen über die russische
Armee laut unabhängigen Medien soll ja
schien vor Gericht gesagt haben Putin
sei ein Kriegsverbrecher aber hinter
Gittern bleibe er
ebenso der US-Journalist evengerich er
stand am Dienstag vor Gericht
georgekovic soll geheime Informationen
über eine russische Waffenfabrik
gesammelt haben für die US-Regierung die
und girzkovic selbst bestreiten die
Spionage Vorwürfe im drohen bei einer
Verurteilung bis zu 20 Jahre Haft
noch höher ist die Strafe im Fall
Wladimir karamusa der russische
Oppositionspolitiker muss für 25 Jahre
in ein Straflager unter anderem wegen
Hochverrats und der Verbreitung von
Falschinformationen so dass Gericht am
Montag es ist die höchste Strafe die
bisher gegen ein Oppositionellen in
Russland verhängt wurde
haraschinski wie ist ihre Reaktion auf
diese Urteile
ja diese Urteile lassen uns natürlich an
die alten Zeiten erinnern
ich muss aber sagen dass in der späten
Sowjetunion unterbrechen gab es solche
Urteile für Worte nicht es ist wichtig
zu verstehen dieser
Urteile verurteilen frei gesprochene
Worte
ist unter anderem wegen Hochverrat
verurteilt aber unter diesem Hochverrat
versteht man die Kritik der russischen
Staates
in üblichen Ländern in demokratischen
Staaten gibt es dafür keine Strafen und
wir können sehen wie man ganz frei und
ganz hart in den meisten Ländern der
Welt die Regierung kritisieren kann
und es ist natürlich eine hohe Strafe
aber das ist egal ob das fünf oder 25
Jahre sind das ist inakzeptabel das
heißt dass die Regierung Angst vor
Worten hat das ist eine schwache
Regierung und wird scheitern
was bezweckt der Kreml mit diesem und
den anderen urteilen
eigentlich wenn man die Sachen beim
Namen nennt dieser Urteile sind nicht
weniger als Terror das ist ein Versuch
die Gesellschaft einzuschüchtern ein
Versuch die
Gesellschaft dazu zu bringen dass es
denn Anweisungen da macht folgt das ist
offensichtlich
und unter Druck stehen nicht nur die
Prominenten
Oppositionellen aber auch ganz einfache
Menschen
die einfach Ihre Kritik geäußert haben
das macht man dafür damit jeder Mensch
unsicher wird und Angst hat frei zu
sprechen
das wird aber kein langfristigen Effekt
oder Wirkung haben
wir haben hier in Deutschland das große
Glück in einem Land zu leben in deinem
indem man seine Meinung frei äußern kann
und gerade in dieser Sendung sind für
froh über die Kommentare und die Fragen
unserer Userinnen und User deshalb
möchte ich die auch gerne mit in die
Sendung einbeziehen wenn Sie oder Ihr
Fragen oder Kommentare habt dann
schreibt sie in die Kommentare oder per
Mail an ZDF heute - live at zdf.de und
ich gucke mal ein bisschen welche
Kommentare schon gekommen sind hier gibt
es sehr viel Anerkennung von den
Userinnen und Usern einer schreibt über
Youtube wow sie sind noch in Moskau das
ist mutig und ein User hat die Frage
haben Sie keine Angst verhaftet und
abgeurteilt zu werden mit einer
fingierten Anklage
das ist eine seltsame Frage natürlich
gibt es diese Gefahr und diese Gefahr
ist aktuell für alle die nicht
einverstanden sind mit der Position der
Regierung aber selbst der
regierungsmeinungsumfragen zufolge der
cremessprecher des Korf hat sie zitiert
ungefähr 20 Prozent der Bevölkerung sind
mit der heutigen Politik nicht
einverstanden das sind Leute die keine
Angst haben in der Meinung zum Frage das
zu sagen das heißt ich bin nicht der
einzige
das haben auch die
Gerichtsverfahren gezeigt ganz viele
Leute sind zu diesen Verfahren gekommen
obwohl das ein Arbeitstag war und die
Zeit war ungünstig wenn man einen Job
hat und sich in dieser Gericht in dieses
Gerichtsverfahren zu gehen und es gab
ganz wenig Platz im Gerichtssaal nicht
destotros hunderte von Menschen sind
hingekommen da sind Leute die
offensichtlich nicht einverstanden sind
in der Regierung das heißt
es gibt noch
Oppositionelle in Russland
sie sind nicht weniger geworden
und sie glauben auch dass sie sich nicht
weiterhin davon einschüchtern lassen
wenn es solche Urteile wie diese in
dieser Woche gab 25 Jahre Straflager als
Urteil als drohendes Urteil für mögliche
Oppositionelle
natürlich das ist unangenehm und
natürlich will niemand hinter Gitarren
landen
aber man kann auch an das folgende
denken es gab auch Zeiten in Russland
als man nicht nur die Gefahr der
Haftstrafe hatte sondern die Gefahr der
Todesstrafe aber selbst damals gab es
Leute die keine Angst hatten nicht
einverstanden zu sein danke diesen
Leuten ist die russische Gesellschaft
sie will Gesellschaft noch haben Leben
dank diesen Leuten gibt es die Tradition
der Freiheit in unserem Lande
deswegen denke ich dass es diese
Verbindung
immer noch gibt diese Kette wird nicht
reißen
sehr wichtig
für die meisten Menschen manche
verstehen das aber nicht ganz gleich
es gibt hier wenn ich in die Kommentare
gucke sehr sehr viel Zuspruch und
wahnsinnig viel Respekt davor was sie in
Russland tun ein User schreibt über
Youtube danke an die mutigen Menschen in
Russland hut ab vor ihnen allen lassen
sie uns auf Ihre Arbeit blicken auf das
was mir
Memorial tut wir fassen das kurz
zusammen
dezember 2022 Jan raczynski nimmt als
Vorsitzender von Memorial den
Friedensnobelpreis für Russlands älteste
und bekannteste
Menschenrechtsorganisationen zusammen
mit menschenrechtern aus Belarus und der
Ukraine
Memorial setzt sich seit 1988 für die
Aufarbeitung von politischer Verfolgung
und für Aufklärung über die
menschenrechtssituationen in Russland
ein dort ordnet der Oberste Gerichtshof
Ende 2021 die Auflösung der Organisation
an weil Memorial gegen das Gesetz für
sogenannte ausländische Agenten
verstoßen habe
ja wie können sie denn unter den
jetzigen Bedingungen überhaupt arbeiten
wie ich bereits erwähnt habe
diese Situation ist nicht die
schrecklichste im Vergleich zu dann
Zeiten die unser Land im 20 Jahrhundert
erlebte und natürlich dieser
Friedensnobelpreis sollte an Arsene
reginski an den ersten Vorsitzenden von
Memorial gehen
er hat an eigenem Leibe erlebt was
Depression heißt er
saßlager obwohl es für ihn die
Möglichkeit gab das Land zu verlassen
aber er hat entschieden im Lande zu
bleiben das war seine Wahl ja und wir
arbeiten weiter warum diese Arbeit
brauchen tausende und Millionen von
Menschen
das ist jetzt nicht unsere Laune das zu
machen das ist eine Notwendigkeit
das ist notwendig für viele Menschen
zählen möchten von den Schicksalen ihren
Verwandten erfahren viele möchten über
die Schicksale ihrer Familien erfahren
das ist eine Notwendigkeit die von der
Regierung nicht zerstört werden kann
das heißt unsere Arbeit wird gebraucht
das ist die Erinnerungsarbeit der
Erinnerung an die Repression der
Vergangenheit und das Wissen über
Menschenrechtsverletzungen heutzutage
das ist für uns in Memorial
zwei Sachen die miteinander verbunden
sind wir verstehen was die
Taten von Vergangenheit waren und wir
sehen was die Spuren von diesen Taten in
der Gegenwart sind und sobald man das
noch braucht werden wir das fortsetzen
nun gab es zuletzt auch Durchsuchungen
bei Ihnen und in den Räumen der
Organisation unter dem Vorwand perfider
Vorwürfe lassen Sie sich davon
einschüchtern
in diesem Fall lasse ich mich davon
nicht einschüchtern das war
wahrscheinlich gerade das Ziel
aber dieser Vorwürfe sind tatsächlich
perfide
diese
ausgebildet hat uns wird vorgeworfen
Nationalsozialismus
zu rehabilitieren zu versuchen und das
sagt man an die Menschen die genau
Gegenteil tun wir haben uns damit
befasst die Erinnerung an die Opfer von
Nationalsozialismus wach zu halten bevor
der Staat das gemacht hat zum Beispiel
die
Zwangsarbeiter viele von uns haben
unsere Verwandten im Großen
Vaterländischen Krieg verloren viele von
unseren Verwandten haben in dem Krieg
gekämpft das heißt diese Vorwürfe sind
tatsächlich perfide und falsch
und das ist das macht uns keine Angst
aber er Empörung
hier kommt viele Fragen an Sie einen
User möchte wissen wie es die allgemeine
Stimmung in Moskau merkt man eine
Anspannung in der Gesellschaft wie
nehmen sie das wahr
schwer zu sagen man hat nicht genug
Informationen
mein Freundeskreis mein Bekanntenkreis
ist jetzt nicht so groß dass ich
allgemeine Schlussfolgerungen sehen kann
man fühlt natürlich diese Spannung warum
ja es gibt
fernsehpropaganda und diese Propaganda
im Fernsehen ist viel aggressiver als du
denn so wird Zeiten es gibt
hasswert verbreitet und ein großer Teil
der Gesellschaft
ist in einem psychologischen Zustand der
Hysterie und da sieht man ihn
verschiedenen Formen
und natürlich ist es dann nicht
verwunderlich dass es diese Spannung
unter den heutigen Bedingungen gibt wenn
man das beobachtet was gerade läuft das
ist nicht verwunderlich
eine andere Frage beschäftigt sich mit
der Präsenz der Opposition in Russland
Chris fragt werden andere Politiker
außer Putin überhaupt wahrgenommen
das ist eines der Hauptprobleme in
Russland wir haben praktisch keinen
politischen Raum
wir haben keine Diskussion
Diskussionen die ihr Gesellschaftsfragen
betreffen würde
das alles wurde vernichtet
man hat die Wahlen gefälscht dafür man
hat die
Wahlgesetze dementsprechend novelliert
und jetzt ist es zum Beispiel unmöglich
als Beobachter bei den Wahlen zu
arbeiten alle
Oppositionellen Politiker sind verbannt
des Landes oder auch sitzen im Gefängnis
oder überhaupt keine Möglichkeit haben
die Gesellschaft anzusprechen
das macht die Situation sehr schwierig
und unvorhersehbar
eine Userin namens Amy Mac fragt oder
sagt ich finde es so mutig in Russland
zu bleiben wie halten Sie das aus
ja das halten viele Menschen aus wir
bereits gesagt 20 Prozent die in den
Meinungsumfragen offen erklärt haben die
sind mit der Politik der Regierung nicht
einverstanden das sind Millionen viele
Millionen von Menschen
natürlich es ist sehr schwer
das
Geschehnisse zu beobachten es ist
sehr schwierig mit
keiner Meinungsfreiheit zu leben ohne
demokratische Freiheiten aber wir sind
immer noch da wir arbeiten weiter wir
versuchen weiter
einerseits die Erinnerung an die
Vergangenheit war zu heißen zu erklären
was ist in der Vergangenheit gab und
auch die Gegenwart zu erklären ich
glaube den Menschen die hier geblieben
sind sie lernen ganz viel gerade jetzt
zusammen zu arbeiten
zu koordinieren das ist für die
Regierung sehr unangenehm aber genau das
rufen sie mit ihren Begrenzungen hervor
stellen Sie sich vor es gibt keine
Möglichkeit in der Zeitung im Fernsehen
im Radio zu sprechen in dieser Situation
suchen diese Menschen nach
Gleichgesinnten so entstehen diese
gesellschaftlichen und dieser Prozess
kann nicht gestoppt werden
sagt der Vorsitzende von Memorial in
Moskau Jan raczynski vielen Dank dass
Sie bei uns in der Sendung waren und
alles Gute für Sie
was wir deine
auf Wiedersehen
ja und bei mir hier im Studio in Mainz
ist unsere Russland Korrespondentin Nina
Niebergall Nina du bist quasi unser
Fenster nach Moskau obwohl du derzeit
von hier berichtest kannst du kurz diese
Situation erklären
genau ich berichte über Russland aber
nicht aus Russland ich arbeite eng
zusammen mit einem Team was in Moskau
noch vor Ort ist was mich versorgt mit
Informationen mit Interviews die
sprechen mit Leuten auf der Straße oder
anderswo und ich bin aber eine
derjenigen die davon betroffen ist dass
aktuell wenig Visa und Akkreditierung
also Arbeitserlaubnisse für Russland
ausgegeben werden das heißt ich warte
seit einem dreiviertel Jahr auf meiner
Kreditierung für Russland und auch dort
zu arbeiten aber seit Kriegsbeginn ist
das eben deutlich schwieriger geworden
die russischen Behörden geben deutlich
weniger Akkreditierung raus und
bestehende werden deutlich schwieriger
damit sind wir bei der Situation der
Journalisten lass uns den Fall
aufgreifen den wir auch vorhin schon
gehört haben der us-kollege
görschkowitsch dessen Anhörung diese
Woche stattgefunden hat und der nach wie
vor dort in Russland auf seine
Verurteilung quasi wartet in einem
spionageprozess man weiß noch nicht
genau was da rauskommt aber wie sehr hat
seine Festnahme und jetzt auch dieser
Prozess eure Arbeit verändert ja für die
Korrespondenten und korrespondentinnen
vor Ort ist die Situation dadurch noch
schwieriger geworden sie war sowieso
schon schwierig das liegt vor allem an
zwei Gesetzen oder mehreren
Gesetzesänderungen die kurz nach
Kriegsbeginn beschlossen wurden die
Zielen ab auf eine Diskreditierung und
Falschaussagen über die Armee zumindest
in der in der russischen Nation wird das
so dargestellt das heißt Journalisten
aber auch Aktivisten oder auch normale
Menschen die die die die Armee
kritisieren über die russische
Kriegsführung in einer Art und Weise
sprechen wie es dem Kreml nicht passt
laufen Gefahr bestraft zu werden und
zwar mit Geldstrafen aber auch mit
Haftstrafen von bis zu 15 Jahren und
diese Festnahme von gershkowitsch er
wurde ja als Spion angeklagt als Spion
bezeichnet und das hat noch mal eine
neue Qualität da reingebracht weil er
eben nicht mit Diskreditierung der Armee
beschuldigt wurde sondern quasi von der
Straße weg festgenommen wurde jetzt in
einer in meinem russischen Gefängnis
sitzt in U-Haft sitzt und Gefahr läuft
ja zu 20 bis zu 20 Jahren verurteilt zu
werden Nina dann lass uns noch mal auf
das eingehen was wir gerade gehört haben
in diesem Gespräch ähm haben wir von
einem unglaublichen Mut der Menschen vor
Ort gehört und sehr viel
Wille sich diesem System
entgegenzustellen und Wege zu finden in
der Opposition
opp infektionsarbeit zu machen jetzt
sehen wir aber auch Urteile wie gegen
den Vater dieses Mädchens der dieses
Bild gemalt hat das zeigt dass die
Repressionen des Regimes nicht nur gegen
prominente krimmelkritiker wirken
sondern quasi in der Breite mit der
Drohung schwerer Strafen an alle die da
quasi ihre Meinung äußern wie verändert
das die Situation dort
einerseits gehört natürlich auch zur
Wahrheit dass durchaus viele Menschen
hinter Putin stehen seine Politik
mittragen die Staatspropaganda wirkt in
Russland also wir hören auch häufig wenn
wir Umfragen mit der Kamera auf der
Straße machen dass die Leute eins zu
eins die Sätze aus dem Staatsfernsehen
eins zu eins die Sätze der Propaganda
wiederholen also auch das darf man nicht
außer Acht lassen und andererseits ist
es natürlich so nicht jeder findet den
Krieg gut nicht jeder findet Putins
Politik gut aber die Leute haben
tatsächlich Angst und das liegt daran
raschinski hat das vorhin ja das vorhin
gesagt dass eben
quasi gezielt Angst und Verunsicherung
unter den Menschen provoziert wird durch
solche Fälle wie beispielsweise von von
dem Vater dessen Tochter eben dieses
Bild gemalt hat wo im Prinzip in unseren
Augen nichts besonders schlimmes
passiert ist das ist ein Mann der war
nicht bekannt und solche Fälle gibt es
zu Hunderten wahrscheinlich zu Tausenden
ich kann noch eines skurrile Geschichte
vielleicht aus den vergangenen Tagen
erzählen da wurde ein Mann der in der
Metro saß in Russland hat durch sein
Handy gescrollt und hatte offensichtlich
ukrainische Flaggen und ukrainische
Musik auf seinem Handy wurde dennunziert
von einer Person die in seiner Nähe saß
und quasi an der nächsten Metrostation
festgenommen und solche Fälle schüren
natürlich eine wahnsinnige Unsicherheit
und das ja glaube ich kann man durchaus
ähm quasi als Grund heranziehen dass so
viele Leute auch nicht offene Kritik
oder offenen Protest äußern und Russland
dann lass uns über eine andere Sache
sprechen die auch für viel
Verunsicherung gesagt hat nämlich die
Entscheidung dass die Menschen bzw die
Männer sind hauptsächlich Männer ähm
dort elektronisch zu Armee einberufen
werden können du hast dazu ein Stück
gemacht und das schauen wir uns
gemeinsam an
für sie könnte es bald an die Front
gehen wer den Einberufungsbescheid
zugestellt bekam musste sich in einem
Rekrutierungsbüro melden oder verließ
schnell das Land so war es bisher nun
ist das nicht mehr möglich mit seiner
Unterschrift besiegelte Putin am späten
Freitagabend das Schicksal von
Zehntausenden möglicherweise Millionen
das Gesetz wurde im Eilverfahren durchs
russische Parlament gebracht
eingesetzt zu verabschieden nachdem wir
nur in einem Fernsehinterview davon
gehört und gerade mal zwei Stunden den
Text dieses Gesetzes durchlesen konnten
das ist in meiner Erinnerung noch nie
vorgekommen
nun werden einberufungsbescheide auch
elektronisch zugestellt ab dem Moment
darf das Land nicht mehr verlassen
werden der einberufene hat 20 Tage um
sich zum Dienst zu melden sonst ist der
den Führerschein los kann keine Kredite
mehr aufnehmen Unternehmen gründen oder
größere Geschäfte abwickeln
viele wehrfähige Männer sind längst
geflohen vor der teilmobil-machung im
September etwa nach Georgien dort
unterstützt Gregoris wird Lin seitdem
Russen die das Land verlassen wollen
[Musik]
die Situation hat sich mit dem Gesetz
offensichtlich geändert die Behörden
haben alles getan um sicherzustellen
dass jederzeit genug Soldaten für die
Front mobilisiert werden können
in Russland geht nun die Angst um vor
einer neuen mobilisierungswelle nur
diesmal gäbe es keine Möglichkeit mehr
zur Flucht
tja ich habe es gerade schon gesagt Nina
das Wort Verunsicherung trifft es das
was diese diese Entscheidung
hervorgerufen hat dort in der
Bevölkerung im Moment hält sich die
Verunsicherung von dem was ich was wir
hören noch in Grenzen weil die
offiziellen sehr darauf bedacht sind zu
sagen erstmal zieht dieses Gesetz ab auf
Menschen die wehrdienstleisten sollen
die sowieso
mobilisiert wurden und quasi versucht
haben dieser Mobilisierung zu entgehen
und da wird jetzt erstmal ein also
lupholz sozusagen geschlossen nämlich
menschen die vorher versucht haben der
Einberufung zu entgehen indem sie
beispielsweise nicht an ihrem Wohnort
anzutreffen waren indem sie sich
umgemeldet haben umgezogen sind die sind
quasi dem Fakten Gang dass jemand Ihnen
einen Brief überreicht hat das läuft so
ähnlich wie mit wie in Deutschland wenn
man wenn man quasi unterzeichnen muss
wichtige Post bekommen hat und das quasi
wird jetzt hier mit geschlossen diese
diese lupholz nämlich wenn jetzt die
Einberufung elektronisch in dieses
Online-System eintrudelt gilt man
automatisch als einberufen und kann ab
dem Moment das Land nicht mehr verlassen
das haben wir ja einen Beitrag gerade
gehört aber es gibt durchaus viele
Beobachter die sagen dass damit schafft
Putin die Grundlage auch für eine
nächste mobilisierungswelle und auch
noch mal quasi für eine größere
mobilisierungswelle von der tausende
zehntausende betroffen sein können per
Mausklick an die Front schreibt hier
einen User es gibt verschiedene Versuche
offenbar
Soldaten dafür zu gewinnen in diesen
Krieg äh zu gehen du hast uns einen
Tweet mitgebracht den schauen wir uns
gerade mal gemeinsam an und ich werde
gleich geschimpft weil ich nicht in der
Lage bin den größer zu machen aber ich
hoffe das geht auch so Nina was was
sehen wir hier
ja wir sehen im Prinzip einen Werbeclip
mobilisierungsbälle von der 1000 ich
höre jetzt gerade noch irgendwie ein
Störgeräusch auf dem Ohr aber genau wir
sehen wir sehen in Werbeclip einen
imageclip der sozusagen an die
Männlichkeit appelliert und darauf
abzielt dass hier sehen wir ein
Taxifahrer das doch der Taxifahrer wenn
er in der Lage ist zu kämpfen lieber an
die Front gehen soll als seinem Beruf
als Taxifahrer nachgehen soll also eine
Imagekampagne was glaubst du wie
erfolgreich wird sein und ist die Teil
einer größeren Kampagne Leute fürs
Militär zu begeistern
ja es ist durchaus so dass man in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen beobachten kann
dass immer mehr auch um freiwillige
geworden wird das liegt vor allem daran
dass das putin-regime Bilder wie wir sie
im September gesehen haben vermeiden
möchte damals sind Jahrzehntausende aus
Russland vor der teilmobil-machung
geflohen über die Grenzen nach Georgien
wir haben diese Menschenmassen gesehen
das heißt das Regime hat natürlich ein
Interesse daran dass ich so viele
Menschen wie möglich freiwillig melden
aber es gäbe diese Werbekampagne nicht
wenn sich sowieso schon viele Leute
freiwillig melden würden also es ist
schwer zu sagen wie erfolgreich die sind
am Ende dieses Werbeclips wurde auch
darauf abgezielt dass es auch Geld dafür
geben wird umgerechnet war da von 2300 €
die Rede das ist nicht wahnsinnig viel
das kann aber gerade für Menschen die in
ärmeren Regionen die auf dem Land in
Russland leben sondern Anreiz sein ja
auch diesen Weg einzuschlagen und eben
in der Ukraine zu kämpfen
vielen Dank unsere Russland
Korrespondentin Nina nibagall zu Gast
heute im heute live-studio Dankeschön
Nina für deine Expertise und wir machen
hier bei ZDF heute live weiter mit einem
ausgewiesenen Russland Experten den wir
auch noch in diese Sendung holen wollen
nämlich Nico lange der ist zugeschaltet
aus Berlin und Herr Lange wenn ich hier
in die Kommentare gucke dann sind viele
sehr beeindruckt von Herrn raczynski den
wir ja zu Beginn der Sendung gesehen
haben und seine Mut und auch seine
Hoffnung auf Demokratie und in diese
Richtung gehen ganz viele Fragen hat die
Demokratie in Russland zukünftig noch
eine Chance was muss passieren damit
wieder Fähre und demokratische Wahlen in
Russland stattfinden können was ist ihre
Meinung
ich bin auch beeindruckt von Herrn
raschinski auch dass er sich so weiter
äußert das ist wie er sagt ja auch
deswegen weil er weiß dass es viele gibt
in Russland die mit dem Regime nicht
einverstanden sind manche trauen sich
das sogar in Umfragen zu sagen aber man
muss auch annehmen dass es viele gibt
die sich eben nicht trauen im Moment
etwas zu sagen aber für die ist es ganz
wichtig wenn sich andere öffentlich
äußern dass die oppositionellen
verurteilt werden dient dem Ziel dass
dieser Unmut den es ja gibt über der den
ja auch gesprochen worden ist hier heute
in dieser Sendung dass der sich nicht
kanalisieren kann das ist keine Anführer
gibt und Wladimir karamusa war der
letzte der noch in Freiheit war und
deswegen ist er jetzt verurteilt worden
russland hat Potenzial für eine
demokratische Entwicklung also man
sollte nicht den Glauben die sagen also
wenn Putin nicht mehr da wäre dann würde
es noch schlimmer kommen es gibt viele
Menschen die ein anderes Russland wollen
und wir können hoffen dass die eines
Tages die Chance dazu haben werden was
ist jetzt als nächsten Schritt braucht
ist das Russland diesen imperialen
Angriffskrieg den Putin begonnen hat
klar verliert dass er nicht zusätzliches
Land gewinnt oder irgendwie ermutigt
wird auf diese Art und Weise weiter zu
machen das ist glaube ich das wichtigste
was passieren muss damit auch in
Russland dann eine positive Entwicklung
irgendwann mal eine Chance hat wir
sprechen jetzt aktuell definitiv nicht
von einer Demokratie aber von was
sprechen wir von einer Diktatur von
einem autoritären Staat wie würden sie
es bezeichnen
man muss glaube ich konstatieren dass
Putins autoritäres Regime
sich immer weiter in Richtung einer
Diktatur entwickelt hat und das mit
Beginn des Krieges in dem ja nicht nur
Leute verurteilt werden jetzt weil zum
Beispiel die Tochter ein Bild gemalt hat
oder weil sie mit einem weißen Blatt
Papier demonstrieren im Laufe dieses
Krieges ja ständig auch Gesetze
verschärft werden harte Strafen
ausgesprochen werden können alles
mögliche bestraft werden kann also diese
Diktatur wandelt sich zu einem
totalitären Regime
ist ein stalilismus Vergleich wie wir
ihn ja mitunter hören aus ihrer Sicht
angebracht
Putin selbst sorgt doch für den
Stalinismus vergleichen mit dieser
Ideologie die er aus dem Großen
Vaterländischen Krieg gemacht hat der ja
der Sowjetunion gehört den er aber für
Russland vereinnahmt und mit diesem Kult
das ist sogar gut ist wenn viele
Menschen in einem Krieg fallen weil das
zeigt wie ernst man es meint also da
sind doch stalinsche Elemente und Putin
selbst hat doch dafür gesorgt dass
Wolgograd für einen Tag wieder in
Stalingrad umbenannt wurde also er
zeichnet ganz gezielt diese Parallelen
zu Stalin
hier gibt es eine Frage die gebe ich
jetzt einfach mal an sie weiters wenn
Odendahl fragt über Facebook noch mal zu
dieser online einen Berufung die wir
gerade thematisiert haben ist das nicht
aus Putins Sicht gefährlich das
Informationen über die Truppenstärke
abgefangen werden können Sie das
irgendwie einschätzen bei dieser
online-berufung geht es ja nicht um
Informationen über die Truppenstärke es
geht nur darum dass die Menschen die
diese einberufungsbescheide kriegen als
zugestellt betrachtet werden können auch
wenn man sie nicht persönlich
angetroffen hat oder sie irgendwo
physisch getroffen hat und ihnen diese
Dinge überreichen konnte damit versucht
man
das Ausweichen zu erschweren aber
Informationen über die Stärke der
russischen Armee kann man da nicht
ableiten die Russen sind ja nicht dumm
die Russen informieren sich auch und die
Nutzung z.B von vpn-netzwerken ist sehr
stark gestiegen in den letzten Monaten
während dieses Krieges die Russen wissen
ja dass sehr viele Soldaten fallen dass
das unattraktiv ist so dieser Truppe zu
gehen und das Russland auch nichts
erreicht in diesem Krieg und das auch
eine ukrainische Gegend Offensive kommen
wird also es ist eher finde ich ein
Zeichen der Schwäche und der
Verzweiflung wenn man jetzt all diese
Maßnahmen ergreift und irgendwie noch
Leute dazu zu bewegen in die russische
Armee zu kommen
ansprechen hier fragt über Youtube
jemand wie würde sich an russischer
Rückzug jetzt springen hier die
Kommentare weg und es kommen so viele
nach dass der den ich jetzt an Sie
weitergeben wollte schon wieder weg ist
da ist er wie würde sich ein russischer
Rückzug bei einer erfolgreichen
ukrainischen Frühlingsoffensive in
Russland innenpolitisch auswirken weil
sie das gerade angesprochen haben
die Russen wissen auch jetzt schon dass
dieser Angriffskrieg von Putin dass der
kein großer Erfolg ist da kann die
Propaganda noch so viel
Tönen das ist allen klar man sollte auf
jeden Fall nicht den Fehler machen zu
denken wenn Russland die Ukraine
verlassen muss wenn es also kein Land
dazu gewinnt durch diesen imperialen
Angriffskrieg dann wäre das irgendeine
existenzielle Bedrohung für Russland das
ist die Erzählung die Putin versucht
indem er den Angriffskrieg im Grunde mit
der Verteidigung im Großen
Vaterländischen Krieg gleichsetzt das
ist aber falsch wenn Russland in der
Ukraine den Krieg verliert also das
Gebiet wieder verlassen muss dann kann
Russland weiterleben hat vielleicht
sogar eine Chance auf eine bessere
Entwicklung also man sollte sich dann
nicht erzählen lassen dass das für
Russland eine existenzielle Bedrohung
wäre sicherlich wird es Diskussionen
geben im Land und Putin als Person weil
er diesen Krieg angefangen hat und er
persönlich diese Entscheidung getroffen
hat und es wird sicherlich auch breitere
Diskussionen geben unter den russischen
Eliten ob es denn das wert da diese
Dinge diese Dinge zu tun und diesen
Krieg so zu führen aber diese Diskussion
gibt es ja auch jetzt schon in
vielleicht und dieser vorgehaltener Hand
und nicht so sichtbar für uns aber ganz
sicher die sind diese Diskussionen noch
jetzt schon da
lassen Sie uns noch einen Aspekt
beleuchten der in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten für Aufsehen gesorgt hat und
zwar die Rolle russischer militärblogger
wir erinnern uns an den Fall des einen
der in St Petersburg einem Anschlag zum
Opfer gefallen ist und der dann auch
beerdigt wurde unter der Teilnahme unter
anderem von Wagner Chef prigoschin und
von anderen ultra-nationalisten die dort
ihre Unterstützung noch mal kundgetan
haben wenn wir uns angucken was diese
äußern dann sehen wir offensichtlich
dürfen die Kritik an der Armee üben
dürfen auch den Krieg thematisieren
wird damit zweierlei Maß gemessen warum
werden Oppositionelle zu 25 Jahren
Straflager verurteilt und militärblogger
dürfen da frei ihre Meinung äußern oder
was steckt da dahinter
es gibt ja berechtigten Grund zur
Annahme dass das gewaltsame Vorgehen
gegen diese militärblogger durchaus vom
russischen Verteidigungsministerium oder
vom russischen Regime ausgehen könnte
insofern ist es vielleicht gar nicht so
dass die sich frei bewegen können
zumindest gibt es da versuche sie
einzuschränken putin ist da glaube ich
mit etwas konfrontiert dass man
bezeichnen könnte als die Geister die
ich rief werde ich heute nicht mehr los
denn er hat sich ja mit diesen extremen
Nationalisten eingelassen hat sich von
ihnen unterstützen lassen aber aus deren
Sicht geht er jetzt nicht weit genug die
wollen so etwas wie einen totalen Krieg
die wollen die Einberufung aller und
etwas viel stärkeres als die sogenannte
spezialoperation und er steht unter
Druck weil er keine militärischen
Erfolge vorzuweisen hat und wird da
ständig korrigiert und verbessert und
von da gibt es immer Ideen wie man denn
jetzt eigentlich militärisch Vorankommen
könnte das ist ganz sicher eine
Bedrohung für Putin und viele dieser
Auseinandersetzungen laufen ja zwischen
dem Verteidigungsministerium und der
Wagner ab manchmal gibt es auch
Absetzungen von bestimmten Generälen
oder Austausch von Personal diese
Konflikte werden ganz sicher jetzt
intensiv weitergehen weil ja die
russische Offensive im Winter keinerlei
Erfolge vorzuweisen hat und Russland
keine militärischen Ziele erreicht hat
man aber damit rechnen muss dass die
Ukraine bei der Gegenoffensive die Sie
vorbereitet die Russen zumindest in
weiten Teilen zurückdrängen wird und
wenn man das dann weiterdenkt und sich
fragt wer Putin denn gefährlich werden
könnte welche Rolle spielt dann
wagner-chef prigoshi
ich glaube dass er in Russland nicht so
eine starke Rolle spielt wie das
manchmal scheint der ist da eher ein
nebenakteur aber es ist natürlich
gefährlich wenn man grundsätzlich
private Militärfirmen hat also im Grunde
Privatarmee es gibt ja mittlerweile
nicht nur die wagnergruppe sondern auch
andere Privatarmeen die aktiv sind und
wenn die
gesetzgeberischen Funktionen oder die
Durchsetzung der Gesetze durch den Staat
in Russland gefährdet ist weil man die
Ordnung nicht mehr aufrecht erhalten
kann weil man zum Beispiel im Krieg zu
viele Leute verloren hat weil man immer
weiter mobilisieren muss wenn man Ärger
hat mit diesem mobil machen dann sind
diese bewaffneten Gruppen natürlich eine
Gefahr für diese innere Ordnung in
Russland aber ich würde Herrn jetzt auch
nicht überschätzen in der Frage wer wird
da Putin gefährlich ist glaube ich
glaube es gibt hinter den Kulissen noch
andere Dinge die da ablaufen aber das
ist wie schon am Hofe des Zaren und
früher im undurchsichtigen Kreml äh bei
den Kommunisten jetzt auch bei Putin das
ist sehr sehr undurchsichtig und für uns
manchmal nicht so richtig zu verstehen
wer da eigentlich die wichtigen Akteure
sind eine Frage noch eines Users an Sie
Eduard Kundt fragt eine Frage an Herrn
Lange wer wäre eigentlich Putins
Nachfolger meiner Meinung nach käme doch
nur patrou-chef in Frage
die Frage ist nicht geklärt Putin hat
schon seit langem nachfolgeproblem
deswegen ist er im Grunde verdammt dazu
Präsident zu bleiben und der Übergang
ist nicht geklärt und wenn man sich die
russische Geschichte des letzten
Jahrhunderts oder noch länger anguckt
scheint das ja ein generelles Problem zu
sein dass häufig die Führer der
Kommunistischen Partei oder die Zahlen
sterben und dann nicht klar ist Werder
Nachfolger wird und ich würde in diesem
Fall auch vermuten es würde zunächst mal
eine große Unsicherheit geben und
vielleicht auch Versuche Kollektiv über
die Nationalen Sicherheitsrat oder über
andere Dinge das Land zu führen bis klar
ist wer tatsächlich ein Nachfolger wird
Herr patrochef ist jedenfalls jemand der
sich vor allen Dingen selbst immer
wieder ins Gespräch bringt
Nicole der Russland Experte war uns in
der Sendung vielen Dank dass Sie bei ZDF
heute live zu Gast waren danke schön
nach Berlin gerne und ich sage auch
Danke und bedanke mich vor allem bei
Frank B der über Youtube schreibt ZDF
heute Nachrichten gute Arbeit danke
geben wir hier als Team wie gesagt
zurück danke fürs kommentieren und
Fragen stellen und bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss